very serious this morning the raging
debate over how to respond to this
pandemic
as it spirals out of control more than
250 000 people in this country have now
had their lives cut short due
to the coronavirus more than 19 000
people have died in this month alone
think about that for just a second and
the daily cases are now up 80 percent
in just the last two weeks our team is
covering the crisis from multiple angles
including the toll on hospitals and
breaking news about another possible
vaccine but first our lead national
correspondent
david begneau is in new york where the
nation's largest public school system is
going remote again
starting this morning david good morning
to you what led mayor bill de blasio to
make this call
well look he said if we had three
percent test positivity rate in the
community i'm going to shut down the
schools but a lot of parents and even
some health experts are saying wait a
minute mr mayor
you're shutting down the schools but you
haven't closed the bars in the
restaurants what kind of sense does that
mean
the mayor's three percent threshold is
reportedly
the most conservative threshold in the
country and in fact the school system
you know what their test positivity rate
is 0.19
i know it was the announcement a lot of
parents were dreading
new york city closing schools and going
to remote learning
100 sending home all the textbooks in
the backpack
so i guess we're ready but uh we're not
really ready it's ridiculous
that restaurants and gyms are still open
and schools are closed it's really
disappointing for parents who are
constantly scrambling
some of the kids are just as frustrated
how long are we gonna not be able to go
in school
they haven't told us you're going to be
at home again
new york city's mayor bill de blasio
called the closure a setback but said
the city and state officials are working
on a framework
to restart in-person learning as soon as
possible
we're going to be deploying a lot of our
testing capacity towards the schools
under this new model new york city is
not alone
in person classes have recently been
suspended in all
or parts of michigan south dakota
georgia
indiana and new mexico suspensions are
planned in philadelphia
and a large kansas district while plans
to reopen schools have been delayed in
las vegas
and chicago here in new york city rates
of transmission inside schools have
remained
very low since schools reopened eight
weeks ago
but the rate of spread outside of the
classroom is an important part of school
safety
according to american federation of
teachers president randy weingarten
new york city should be credited for
doing what no
other major school system did which is
to reopen in-school instruction for kids
in a safe way but having community
spread the way it's now going all across
the country
schools are not impervious to that
you know cbs news has learned that the
white house coronavirus task force
is not calling for schools to close
they're not calling for that because
they say the data doesn't suggest that
the virus is
being a big spreader and spreading its
schools however you know what they all
are calling for closing of indoor dining
and bars anthony
yeah all right david thank you very much
in our next hour we will talk
with new york city mayor bill de blasio
first here on cbs
this morning